ah on avait commencé à couper avec 250
familles dans les débuts là on est à peu
près 900 ville intense plus que 30
minutes pour s'assurer qu'il y aura à
manger pour tous depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire les bénévoles du
collectif ac le feu distribuer une fois
par semaine des denrées alimentaires aux
habitants des quartiers populaires et
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
venir ici chercher de quoi nourrir leur
famille avec la crise
tout a augmenté
plus permettre les marchés ont fermé
permettre d'acheter des d'enlever à au
moins un moment donné donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils soient steve young qui viennent
ici un même si un des confirmands
aujourd'hui c'est pas tout le monde qui
va aller travailler et risque d'avoir
encore du monde
le collectif a vu le jour à
clichy-sous-bois en 2005 au lendemain
des révolte des banlieues
quinze ans après l'un de ses fondateurs
regrette que la situation dans les
quartiers défavorisés n'est pas évolué
on s'aperçoit qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya
des crises dans mon pays les premiers
qui sont touchés de plein fouet ben c
c'est nos territoires c'est la
seine-saint-denis
on le voit c'est pas d'aujourd'hui et ça
c'est juste révélateur symptomatique de
une situation qui était latente et qui
aujourd'hui c'est un peu un peu
l'explosion si aujourd'hui voilà il ya
autant de monde dans une file d'attenté
c'est que les gens sont vraiment dans le
besoin ils veulent pas pu marcher enfin
du footing ou danser dans la rue tout
simplement
mais ils sont là vraiment moi parce que
c'est un besoin de primaire et non
doivent alors se doit de de répondre à
cet appel à ses besoins la halle aux
grains deux mois annoncé des mesures
sociales ces mesures sociales
malheureusement il arrive à zaria
n'arriveront que courant mais c'est
peut-être cours mais pour ces personnes
c'est très très loin dans la file
d'attenté des ménages modestes des
salariés en chômage partiel on arrêt
d'activité une population
particulièrement touchée par le
confinement
un jour je suis arrivée à la maison j'ai
vu ça on en confinement d'accord
la paille à l'hectare nettement baissé
et là c'est parti de l'ice et c'est fini
la situation elle est au fond du trou
malheureusement alors match gagne très
peu je suis à temps partiel n'est pas
atteindre complet donc je regarde car
même si je le dis au monde entier ses
paroles je suis à 807 euros d'obliger
les loyers à payer
j'ai les charges à payer alors moi ce
qui m'aide beaucoup c'est ça
c'est cette association qui me nourrit
je suis à l'arrêt en fait la sécurité
soit sans tarder un petit peu c'est
normal parce qu'ils ont beaucoup de
dossiers mais néanmois voilà donc ne pas
être payé mars et avril ça pèse un petit
peu voilà sachant que les charges quand
il est toujours à tomber les dépenses en
elles mêmes comme sur le rsa tout ça
c'était pas facile donc c'est toujours
ça c'est toujours ça le 13 avril dernier
emmanuel macron a annoncé une aide
exceptionnelle aux foyers les plus
modestes
elle devrait être versée le 15 mai
prochain trop tard pour des populations
dont la situation se dégrade de jour en
jour